zendaya and tom holland are once again
sparking major dating rumors
yeah i do my part where i can for sure
the spider-man franchise co-stars were
spotted getting cozy in los angeles last
week
in the snap tom is seen driving while
zendaya sits in the passenger seat
and we see him reach for zendaya's chin
as he leans in for a kiss
i just feel very lucky and this
paparazzi video shows the pair enjoying
each other's company
and seemingly vibing to some good tunes
as they wait out traffic
i think you know right now it's just the
beginning of this really adorable
romance that we're watching kind of
bloom on camera neither zendaya or tom
have confirmed
any relationship status as of now but
there has been plenty of romance
speculation
in the past so what's the back story
here
let's take a look i am sweating
dating rumors first began in the summer
of 2017
amid the actors worldwide press tour for
spider-man homecoming
have you found that it's hard to date in
hollywood at such a young age of course
it is i mean it's hard to say at any age
i mean it doesn't matter you know where
you are either i mean it's just hard to
say in general
but zendaya shut down the speculation at
the time when she simply called tom one
of her best friends
and a great dude in that august zendaya
told et she wasn't phased by their
romance rumors
things happens all the time and of
course you know we we expected it i mean
it's
it's um it comes with the territory it
comes with the job so it was all good
both stars have been linked to other
people in the years since
last year tom dated actress nadia parks
for a time
even making the relationship instagram
official sharing
this pic with his fans around the same
time zendaya was seen getting close with
euphoria co-star jacob allordy
she's brilliant you know she's beautiful
and she's a she's a wonderful performer
and she just captains the ship perfectly
despite her claims that they were just
friends the two were seen vacationing
in greece and spending time together in
los angeles
now jump to just a few months ago when
we got the first of presumably many tom
and zendaya moments to come this year i
just don't understand why he keeps doing
this you don't understand i feel like
it's pretty obvious
i don't spoil things in this funny
teaser video alongside co-star jacob
battle on
zendaya and tom helped reveal the
official title for the webb slinger's
next movie
spider-man no way home made me one thing
that i've actually spoiled
the last movie title
this is slated to be the third and final
standalone mcu film for holland
while we wait for an official
confirmation or maybe a red carpet
outing
here's a little tom and zendaya cuteness
to hold you over
the pair gushing to e.t about the fun
they have working together
on set they went to the harry potter
studios it's my birthday
it's very exciting very upsetting
because the harry potter studios
were directly outside the studio where i
was working it's not outside it's
literally on
it's literally on the same level so
while they were having so much fun i was
being beaten up by a hydro man
in our behind the scenes uh footage that
we got
there's the most amazing footage of you
and it's spider-man taking a drink on
set
yeah it's an interesting contraption to
say the least basically my eyes
in my mask they clip off they come off
because they're glass and and obviously
the suit is fabric and
they need to clip in and what i can do
is i can take my left one out and
there's a little
like thing that i pull out and then i
put a um
a tube a squeezy tube down into my mouth
and then i can drink
drink from a from a bottle thanks so
much i'm really struggling
but what i found out now is that this
video of you doing that in new york and
this little kid just like
remember the store we were like oh yeah
yeah yeah in a store
there's just a little kid behind him
just watching him drink from his eye
like you're ruining what is happening